group of small online investors trying
to stop wall street
betting against a company have been
blocked by the trading app they were
using the
robin hood app halted the ability to buy
new shares in
gamestop a us video game retailer which
has sent its stocks tumbling again
the small investors had initially hiked
its shares twelve-fold
before the ban match kaiser host of
artists kai's report says the small
investors effort should be praised for
exposing the questionable practices of
big wall street traders
so what these uh traders have done what
these reddit
traders have done is exposed or shined a
light
on the illegal practices of hedge funds
and this should have been addressed many
years ago
because the objective of hedge funds
like melvin
capital which is associated with citadel
that has
on their board uh ben bernanke former
fed chairman
is to put these companies out of
business and to profit
on their collapse and that of course
doesn't help the economy at all and
people lose jobs
so we have to applaud the reddit and the
wall street bets people
for bringing back some law and order and
some
equilibrium to these markets they're
doing the absolute right
thing and we need to support them if we
believe in free markets and if we
believe in capitalism
if we don't and the objective is price
fixing
and to go to a command and controlled
economy in america
then that's what we're going to end up
with if we let hedge funds dominate the
price discovery
and engage in this massive price fixing
that the reddit people have exposed
you